I'm a dietician and this is what I eat
in the leadup to a big holiday meal I
start my day like any other normal day
because I am busy I usually have a
protein smoothie some toasted peanut
butter and some fruit a balanced hunger
crushing combo and super stating protein
in the morning is super important to
balance energy levels and prevent Ting
later on for lunch I don't purposely try
to eat super light or cut calories
because this will basically always
backfire so I made myself a chicken
sandwich on sourdough and served it with
some veggies and hummus on the side then
an hour or so before we leave I try to
have a hunger cresh and combo snack you
never know how long it's going to be
before dinner is served with some of
these fancy dinner parties so I'm just
having a little bowl of cottage cheese
and some fruit to take the edge off it's
really important to me to not arrive at
a holiday party super ravenous because a
I'm not the best house guest when I'm
hungry and B this way I can make more
mindful balanced decisions based around
my usual body cues rather than going
overboard because I am banished in that
moment but let me know how you guys are
handling the holiday party circuit this
season in the comments below